thanks to skillshare for supporting this
episode of journey to the micro cosmos
the first thousand people to click the
link in the description can get a free
trial of skillshare's premium membership
[Music]
so
learning about ecology can make the
world look like one big buffet except
all the dishes
are eating each other
at the start you have the photosynthetic
organisms churning sunlight into sugar
and everything just cascades into
culinary chaos from there
there's ciliates eating algae cillians
eating other ciliates rotifers and fish
and everything else that comes after and
somewhere raining comfortable from its
spot in the middle of all of this
is the copepod
[Music]
at first glance the copapod probably
doesn't seem any more significant than
any other animal i mean
it looks a little strange but
crustaceans usually do
there are more than 20 000 species of
copepods in the world and these various
species have managed to find their way
into just about every type of water no
matter the temperature or the salinity
there are species in freshwater ponds
species and oceans and species deep in
hydrothermal vents
and just as they've managed to find so
many different places to live so have
they found many different ways to live
some swim freely through those waters
others pursue a more parasitic strategy
and some become hosts for parasites
themselves like the guinea worm which
enters the copepod as a larva and leaves
ready to infect whoever has eaten the
copepod
but however many different types of
copepods are out there in the world they
do have a few things in common they
hatch from eggs beginning their lives as
a round not fully formed version of
itself the copapod molts several times
from this larval stage its body
lengthening and forming more pronounced
divisions as it goes through a youthful
copepodite stage and eventually the
copepod reaches its adult form its
segmented body forming a tapered shape
encased in an armored exoskeleton
copapods have a very simple eye that
senses light which they use to orient
themselves in water a few species are
even capable of something like vision
but perhaps the copepod's most essential
sensing comes from its two pairs of
antennae the most noticeable of which is
that almost comically large set that you
see here and along the length of those
antennae are small sensory hairs called
setai that help the copepod detect
changes in its surroundings now those
antennas don't just sense they also help
the copepod mate when a male copepod
finds a female copepod who he likes very
very much he can bend his antenna to
grab her then that might sound like a
funny detail about an equally
funny-looking part of a copepod's body
but it's also part of its success when
you're a tiny animal trying to reproduce
in a big body of water the vastness of
your surroundings makes it enormously
difficult to find a mate it would be
like trying to find a date on tinder
except like 99 of the profiles you're
swiping through are just pictures of
water
so when you find someone you really have
to hold on to them
copapods of course aren't the only
animal facing this challenge there are
lots of animals in the ocean that are
just too tiny to overcome the ocean's
currents and the way that water feels
like honey when you're that size
as a collective they are called
zooplankton and they spend their lives
drifting where the currents take them in
the hopes that food will also be there
the zooplankton's diet makes them a
valuable part of the ecology buffet
because they are at the spot right next
to the organisms who start the whole
thing out munching away at the diatoms
and other photosynthesizers of the water
in the case of copepods scientists
observed individuals of one species
eating around eleven thousand two wait
for it three hundred and seventy three
000 diatoms every day and as beautiful
as diatoms are and as much as we like to
look at them the world would be very
different if there was no one trying to
eat hundreds of thousands of them a day
it would be a buffet with diatoms
spilling out of the trays leaving no
room for anything else
but copepods and their fellow
zooplankton fill that essential
ecological role acting like a middleman
that connects diatoms to the rest of us
and somehow over the millions of years
that copepods have been around they have
become the preeminent zooplankton a kind
of king amongst middlemen dominating
zooplankton populations in many bodies
of water all over the world including
antarctic lakes
in lake baikal in russia the deepest
freshwater lake in the world copepods
are estimated to make up 96 of the
zooplankton population and out in the
oceans copepods reigns supreme
so the question is
how
and the answer is probably much more
complex than any one single trait
especially if we attempt side-by-side
comparisons with every single animal
that makes up the zooplankton of every
single body of water but if we consider
the ocean the vast vast ocean where food
and mates are both difficult to come by
the copepod has a number of talents that
do help it survive
it is for one very sensitive to its
surroundings those hairs and its
antennae detect predators and prey alike
through changes in the water velocity
around it
if the copepod detects a predator it can
quickly jump away using four or five
pairs of legs to jump up to 1 000 body
lengths per second
making the copapod
much faster than other animals of its
size and if the copepod detects prey it
can launch itself into a quick ambush
instead so speed is one advantage that
may help the copepod survive but this
organism doesn't rely on ambushing alone
to sustain itself it is also capable of
a much more sustained search for food by
vibrating some of its appendages which
creates a feeding current that the
copepod can scan and dine upon like it
is its own personal banquet
and these are seemingly small talents
that stack up producing in its totality
an animal that is capable of feeding
escaping and mating its way to success
in the vast open ocean
and with each diatom the copepod eats
their strange regime becomes only more
influential because one day a fish will
probably eat that copepod and eventually
another animal maybe even you will eat
that fish connecting us all to a strange
little crustacean in the sea whose
kingdom
has no boundary
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us we'd like to also say
thank you to skillshare for supporting
this video
the end of the year is just around the
corner and with the new year comes new
year's resolutions but what if this year
you got a jump start on those
resolutions and started today because
let's be honest probably that would be
more likely to succeed in the long term
maybe you're sitting there wishing you
could figure out ways to be more
productive well with thomas frank's
productivity master class on skillshare
you can be he will walk you through the
steps to setting up your own
productivity system to help you be
better at making to-do lists organizing
your files both physical and digital as
well as tackling the dreaded world of
your email inbox
skillshare is an online learning
community that offers membership with
meaning with so much to explore real
world projects to create and the support
of fellow creatives skillshare empowers
you to accomplish real growth it's
curated specifically for learning
meaning there are no ads to distract you
and they're always launching new premium
classes so you can stay focused and
follow wherever your creativity takes
you if you're one of the first thousand
people to click on the link in the
description you can get a free trial of
skillshare's premium membership
the folks you're seeing on the screen
right now they
are a bunch of people who have
definitely can like absorbed some of the
nutrition that once was contained inside
of a copepod but that is also true of
all humans they are also people who have
supported us on patreon patreon is a
place where you can go and give a little
bit of money to the things that you
really think should exist in the world
and all of these people
really think that journey to the micro
cosmos should exist and we agree with
them and we're so thankful to them if
you want to see more from our master of
microscopes and james weiss you can
check out jam and germs on instagram and
if you want to see more from us hey
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby